In Yemen, ex-president Ali Abdullah Saleh says Saudi-led air strikes that hit his home,...
...reducing it to rubble, are an attack against Yemenis.
In the UK, British Prime Minister David Cameron unveils his new cabinet...
...after last week's election victory.
In Macedonia, Macedonians survey damage of Sunday's gun battle...
...between police and an armed group that left 24 dead.
More than two weeks after a deadly earthquake hit the country,...
...people in Nepal are frustrated by the government's slow response.
And finally from Indonesia, four boats carrying some 1,400 migrants...
...from Myanmar and Bangladesh are rescued off the coasts of Indonesia and Malaysia.